for a writer who's never submitted to
the blacklist how does that work the
blacklist um
i think it's important to to point out
is
you
you upload a screenplay
to their website um
and um the website more or less is a
collection of screenplays
that are written by
anybody
anybody can
upload a
screenplay or a tv pilot
to the blacklist it doesn't doesn't
matter who you are or where you are in
the world you can go ahead and do so
and
those scripts are evaluated now the the
one thing is though um you're going to
be paying a monthly fee and that is um i
think the monthly fee is 30
um for for that script to be hosted on
the site
and for each evaluation
you must pay
a 75 fee
now if you have the money to do that
which for some that can be
a little tight to afford
but if you have the money to do that
it's very much worth the while
because
the blacklist is probably the main
um
it's the central access that you will
have
to
the
the the film industry on these days
specifically if you're not in hollywood
and you don't have an agent or some kind
of representation that can submit your
work and get you meetings if you don't
have an access to
a
representation
agent um or a manager that can submit
your scripts
or
get you meetings
so it's worthwhile to
to post your script on the blacklist the
other thing that's really wonderful
about the blacklist
is that the readers
there provide coverage for your scripts
now
this coverage is is good in and of
itself
of
of its own to to promote um the what
what a concise
understanding is of your story
on your
on your blacklist page but it also
is a great tool for you to know where
the flaws are in your script
so you can
you can use it as a balance sheet as to
where you need to
fix areas that
may not be communicating well um if you
if you are a new writer and you are
you you have trouble
taking critic um critique
[Laughter]
or receiving critique it's a great it's
a great um um
[Music]
baptism by fire this is the the the
other thing um in regards to the
blacklist this is um invaluable
um
as you develop your skills as a writer
you have for you
right there at your disposal
a barometer
through which
you can
you can um
you can understand how how strong your
work is
so if you are getting recognition on a
blacklist and and certainly if you're
getting recognition regularly on the
blacklist
um
you
you know that you're ready
to um
to go out into um
into the field or to march out into the
field so to speak
so
if you are trepidatious about a
screenplay that
that you are going to submit to an agent
or a producer
if you
are
a little
unsure
or uncertain
about something that you want to pass on
for consideration to to anybody
try and see if uh you can pass mustard
on the blacklist
um see if um that script um um can get
get you a score of an eight or above if
you are getting an eight or above score
on the blacklist then i think you can be
entirely confident that you um
that your script has
has legs at that point
um so i think that that um
that's what also makes it a wonderful
tool
it's
it's a very good site
because what it does is it
it bridges the gap um between
the industry and
and pretty much anybody
um
anywhere it doesn't
it doesn't exclude
um you out of the process whoever you
are and wherever you are
um
before
on the blacklist existed
we had this um
this arcane version of that and that
simply meant
that you had to be
somewhat in the know
or working
at some
in some strata of the industry to be
able to um
get your scripts read by a reader
at a production company or an agency or
what have you
instead now you can just
go online pay the fees
and have a reader
produce coverage for you that way
in the old days in fact
um
you know they they
sometimes if you were submitting your
script to a producer they'd ask to see
your coverage instead of
your script itself so that they could
get an overview of your script
and you go oh well i have some coverage
here let me let me send that on
on to you you can have a look
um
here on on the blacklist they can simply
go onto the blacklist read your coverage
and then download your script so it's
great and and and and franklin leonard
is a he's a really um
really really really fascinating um
inspiring character um with what he's
done here with his um
with his website um and also his um
his um his advocacy and support of
people in all areas of the writing field
and his um
his strong stance on inclusion so
so uh i'm i i can't say anything but
good things about him and his and what
he's done for for the community
what kind of feedback have you gotten on
some of your work that's made it onto
the blacklist
well uh
i've i've i've been
lucky enough to score high um
a couple times yeah um
that's i've had some good feedback um i
think
i think that
[Music]
as a writer you
you
it's incumbent upon you to run that
gauntlet
that you need to you need to go on there
and um score high on the blacklist you i
mean this is this is where
this is where my my my pride will come
out or let's say my ego as a writer
um where
is like i need to knock i need to i need
to see this this this script this story
whatever knock it out the park somewhere
so it's it's got to knock it out the
park on the blacklist it's got to knock
it out the park
on
on the on a
on a a spot on the nichols fellowship
it's got to knock it out the park
on on say
austin i've never placed on austin but
i'm just going to say that it's got to
knock it out somewhere
um
once it's done that then i'm like okay
well i'm pretty sure it's a good script
you know
or i'm pretty sure it um it will impress
somebody somewhere
so um these are our tools today
that we have
at our disposal at our fingertips
literally in front of us on our screens
that we can use
as barometers
for how good our work is
um
so
you know they should be used you know
you should use them
um and not be
not be afraid you know um
it's um
i know it it can be really daunting to
to
receive criticism and to um
allow others to look at your work but
this is the thing um
is that
first of all you learn not to take um
criticism personally
um that it doesn't mean that you should
necessarily change anything that you're
doing
it
it only offers you one thing
it's perspective
that's it
criticism
gives you perspective now now what does
that mean
well what that means is
that
i can judge the distance
between
what i
am going for
and what lands
that's what that means
so
if i'm if i'm hitting
with something
that where i
i was going for a target
and i know it's hitting
and i'm getting that
feedback
from somewhere else an objective source
i'm getting that feedback
then i know i'm on to something
you know
um
that
that's perspective
um
if you
if you're getting something that's a
little off to the side if someone's
going i'm i'm seeing this as something
else if someone's misunderstanding it
entirely
then you you might want to step back and
adjust
you might want to go oh okay wait i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna change how
this um you know how the second act sort
of um uh moves right here or i'm going
to adjust you know this aspect about the
b story or i'm going to um um give this
character a um you know a long-lost
sister
you know
it's
all these things can mean the difference
between a good script
and a great script
perspective will give you that
perspective will imbue you with
that and when you have that experience
you never you never take criticism
personally
in fact you invite it
and you want to know and you're curious
about people's criticism even if they if
if they're not
even if they're
they're
they are to a certain degree mis
misguided prison criticism
even misguided criticism can enlighten
you as a writer
and make you a better writer
say i'm a screenwriter and i upload my
script to the blacklist and i pay my 75
dollars
am i just getting a one-time
feedback some notes or is that script
now accessible to anybody yes um that is
the case
anybody can read the script on the
blacklist
um
what's cool about that is
that
the the designated readers that you um
that you
pay for or hire to read your scripts
um
will will provide you with feedback but
also the people that
or the industry folks that
go on there and may stumble across your
script or see your log line and just
appreciate your along line also have the
option to um to download your script
and they also have the option to offer
you coverage
so
that's a cool thing i think it's rare
that that ever happens because i've
never
received coverage from someone that have
just has just been perusing my script or
just downloading it um
off of the off the blacklist
now
more than likely what does happen though
is that you you
you get a high score on the blacklist
and that's when you actually get
attention from um
from
from industry readers
and they'll and they'll download your
script um
in numbers
but um
but and that's what you want that's what
you want to try and do
you want to
you know it it can you know let me tell
you it can be expensive
um
if you're paying 75 dollars pop as you
revise your script to try and make it
better and better so you get some kind
of attention
you know that can add up after some time
but if you do um i'm i'm you score high
um
[Music]
you know that can be offset by the fact
that you're going to have you know
a lot of a lot of people downloading
your script
because i just said did you get any
feedback and you said you scored high
um i don't know if we went into
if there was any negative feedback and
maybe we don't want to go there
well yeah i mean
yeah there's negative feedback but that
but that's but that's a part of what
what screed writing is
you know
you need
to get negative feedback at some point
you know you're not
if
you someone is not going to like
something that you've written
somewhere
you know for some reason the what you
need to know is why
that's that's that's it you know you
there you
um there's a there's a meme that's
circulating right now
that um by um
by um
um
that's that features um jordan peele
and jordan peele says
you know
you know how you handle criticism
this is how you handle criticism
when i have a screenplay
and i send it out there
and someone says
you know there's a scene in there it's
just way too violent
you know i just
it took me out of the screenplay
you know i i think you should do
something about that
he's like i don't go home and take that
scene out of the screenplay
no what i do is i go back and i work on
that screenplay and find the thread that
substantiates that violence
and i and i make that i i i express that
in a more um succinct and better way
that's that that that's
you know that's what he says and i'm
paraphrasing but
that's basically
what he is um
is expressing
and um
you know that's my say
my exact same attitude
you know negative negative feedback
sometimes is your best feedback
sometimes it gives you the best
you get breakthroughs
you know from negative feedback yes
absolutely
you